six-year-old Northwest is sporting a
nose ring she really isn't to beauty but
don't worry guys
it's just a fake mama Kim
kardashian-west took to her Instagram
stories with new photos of her eldest
daughter sporting an edgier look over
the weekend
there's the mother-daughter matching
duck face shot the peace sign pose and
check out this snap of north with
auntie's Kourtney and khloé and their
respective daughters Penelope Disick and
true Thompson Kim captioned the photo
fake nose ring alert as for the occasion
well that would be northeast
great-grandma Mary Jo MJ Campbell's 85th
birthday bash we're definitely a close
family like more than probably normal
the entire Kardashian Jenner crew showed
up to shower MJ with love ahead of her
actual birthday on Friday but all eyes
were on north and her new beau facial
jewelry a closer look shows that the
mini fashionista also accessorized with
braids oversized Sony's and body sticker
jewels applied to her forehead North's
stylish ways come as no surprise you
might remember this photo grandma Kris
Jenner posted in honor of her birthday
on June 15th it's funny everyone thought
she was wearing extensions and she
wasn't yeah that's her hair she just has
really curly hair so I don't really let
her straighten her hair but it was on
her birthday party and on her birthday
trip to New York she wanted straight
hair she loves hair looks that's her
thing and she loves a little bit of
makeup
something North proved last Christmas
when she rocked a bold lip to the family
holiday party but as Kim told et in 2018
her daughter's love for beauty doesn't
and their North what are you doing with
my Mario palette turn around I was
getting ready today and she was a little
too quiet and I look over and she's like
destroying the palette and has just blue
eyeshadow all over her entire
that's not no you put on a shadow she's
really aware of makeup